and are you uh sexually active now I do
sexual things but not
like
yet okay then you are in fact sexually
active
cool he's had his eyes on you since the
first day you moved here my name is Adam
nice to meet you Adam he seems adorable
so I'm going to have a free house if you
want to have a sleepover sleepover
sleepover you've had sex before right um
it's like not really that big of a deal
it's just like d and
V are you on birth control no let's fix
that now then what's the date of your
last period uh I haven't gotten it yet
I'm just starting to wonder do you want
to go see a gynecologist I'm sure it's
fine mom Lindy appears to have MK
syndrome what is that it's a congenital
disorder resulting in Lindy being born
without a uterus cervix or vaginal Canal
but the vagina really is just an amazing
muscle you're just going to have to
stretch it
out start off with this little fella you
know and then you work your way up sort
of to this guy that's the dream
there just think of this like vagina
boot camp what do we have here are these
butt
plugs on my way to you good at what I
do I'm Jack and I'm interex to own who
you are is up to you no one should ever
make you feel ashamed of that oh and I
get mad dates too so don't worry about
that I just want you to feel like a
normal teenage girl I'm not normal stop
trying to fix
everything I'm pissed and sad I can't
have a kid I'm pissed I can't complain
about my period being 16 is just bloody
hell isn't
it
uh well I'm going to let you unpack all
of
that